Berto is next Berto is in Indiana hi
Berto how are you hey Randy how you
doing thank you for having me sure not
gonna help
so my girlfriend and I were in under a
little over $190,000 with the debt and
[Music]
we aren't married there isn't a we you
haven't how much debt does she have well
I have a hundred and twenty I think I
have about a hundred and a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in debt you have
a hundred and fifty and she has 40 yet
well she's a generous woman to be dating
you okay why do you have $150,000 in
debt well a hundred twenty-eight of that
is my house and and then the rest of
that is on a car that I have okay well
that's better news at least at least you
didn't tell me you've got a student loan
debt for a hundred and fifty with a
degree in left-handed puppetry so we're
making progress good it's a house and a
car yeah and what's her 40 um well it's
actually our forty thousand because we
we I co-signed on on the vehicle that
she got so she bought a $40,000 car and
you co-signed on it yes okay and what's
your household income so together it's
about a hundred and fifty thousand okay
and so you guys are walking around
thinking like you're married acting like
you're married violating about six
different rules of relationships asking
for trouble when is it you're planning
to get married sometime sometime soon
here and here in the next year or two
okay
we've been together we've been together
for about three years now
so I mean we we lit so what else and
what's the holdup so the holdup on one
getting married because you're acting
like you're married you're walking
around talking about wee wee wee wee wee
and
bought a car together $40,000 worth that
you can't with your roommate and if she
decides to drive that car off into the
sunset into a ditch and walk away from
you you know what you got a $40,000 debt
and a broken heart
yeah no divorce nobody no judge is gonna
help you they're gonna look at you and
go you made a mess no judge is gonna
help you yeah get married yeah you're
right either quit acting like you're
married get married combine your incomes
then you would have we have an income
because you don't have a household
income dude not under the law now you
may feel like you do all your friends
that are shacked up like you are may
feel like you do but you don't have
under the law you have a roommate and
you cosign for your roommates car that
she couldn't afford an expensive car
that she can't afford and so it's a mess
yeah so that your best shot at cleaning
this mess up is as we used to say in the
old days make an honest woman out of her
and let's get married
and now let's combine our finances
combine our incomes and start to get
these debts cleaned up and basically
you've got two major debts that are cars
is what you're telling me
and then you'll work on your house a
little bit later but you man you you
have no idea you're walking around in a
minefield and you don't even know it and
you're going to step on something it's
gonna go click and it ain't goin pretty
for you so you really have got that you
guys are gonna have to straighten up
here you're gonna make you made a mess
man you really have I mean I know you
don't think you think I've got all weird
over something that's fine
but my job here is not to protect your
feelings it's to protect your life and
that's what I'm here for is to help you
so I hope that helps this is old Dave
giving you the wake-up call ringy-dingy